welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and our boy bruce spinner is
blasting off again
departing planet earth for the stars
beyond and this time not because his
dum-dum alter ego couldn't figure out
how to work the controls this is a car
and courier craft that caused jen and
bruce to veer off the road in episode
one is now bruce's lift as he leaves our
solar system leaving us to wonder
where'd hulk go we have been discussing
some theories over the past week as to
what message this sakura and courier
brought and now based on some clues with
what bruce is bringing with him and his
general demeanor when he's talking to
his cousin we can narrow down the
options and present the likeliest answer
and thanks to boxsu for sponsoring this
video more on their tasty offerings
later the first possible destination is
the obvious sakar the fact that bruce
recognized the ship that caused their
car accident as a sakharan class a
courier craft tells us that bruce as
smart hulk must have spent some time
during the blip learning about
extraterrestrial spacecraft because for
the two years he spent [ __ ] guns to
carve before thor reverted him to human
form in ragnarok banner's mind had no
memory of what had transpired i've been
hulk for two years i'm afraid so
what the hell happened bruce otherwise
simply did not spend enough time on the
planet of cigar to become familiar with
the types of cigar and spacecraft
especially considering how clueless the
guy was when he tried to pilot the
commodore yeah take the wheel no i don't
know how to fly one of these are your
scientists use one of your phds none of
them are for flying alien spaceships
that looks like a gun
also you'll notice in that beach house
lab was hulk's spartan style gladiator
helmet from the sakhar arena a helmet
that bruce certainly did not take with
him when he fled the planet in ragnarok
so hulk must have either returned to
cigar at some point in the past few
years or have been in touch with someone
else from sakaar who had sent him these
things so if bruce now is returning to
sakaar that could lead to this rumored
world war hulk title in marvel phase six
this could adapt the planet hulk
storyline that was partially adapted in
the second act of ragnarok that was a
storyline that featured hulk is a
gladiator warrior marooned on sakhar
after he was banished from earth by the
illuminati in the comics the car is
ruled by the red king he's the one who
oversees the gladiator combat and when
hulk begins to band together with the
other warriors the red king sends kiera
the old strong after hulk but hulk and
cairo fall in love they take over the
planet preside over a utopian sikar but
kyra dies in an explosion and hulk flips
out he blames those earth heroes who
banished him to cigar declaring war on
the illuminati and pretty much all the
avengers and this is how we get the
world war hulk storyline hulk unleashes
hell on the illuminati in the avengers
as a true world breaker hulk beating
black bolt to a pulp flattening reed
richards smashing the thing's head until
hulk is eventually reigned in by century
now there is another storyline following
hulk's son scar that is connected to
this because before she died cair
released a cocoon into a fiery swamp
from which hulk's son scar emerges so
here in the mcu bruce could be returning
to the planet of sakaar to deal with his
son scar all of these comic story lines
are possible and i would love to see a
world war hulk title on marvel's phase
six calendar or just any title that
allows hulk to be hulk again even
briefly because as much as i love ruffa
hulk hulk is meant to be a true
uncontrollable rage monster and overall
i think the mcu has done them dirty we
haven't really gotten to see this guy in
hulk form i would say since that
gladiator fight on ragnarok they would
not let him fight serger thanos kicked
his ass and we haven't gotten to see our
big green meanie since however bruce
banner's current state in she-hulk is a
big reason why i'm a bit skeptical that
this trip on that sakura couriercraft is
leading directly to this kind of world
war hulk storyline because think about
it would smart hulk truly be the most
useful figure to return to a warrior
trash planet like sakhar would he be as
vicious or as lethal or effective in a
sakar gladiator arena as his aggro
monstrous self was if scar was born from
that savage version of hulk would hulk's
meeker more academic alter ego bruce
really want to deal with whatever that
drama is and would he look so casual and
carefree about it here on the ship like
notice bruce surroundings on that cigar
courier craft it's not a brig like he
was abducted and he was being extradited
somewhere against his will no it's a
comfortable office he has his own
personalized desktop setup with a fresh
cup of coffee still steaming which one
must wonder if it takes him several
bottles of alcohol to get drunk how many
cups of coffee does it take him to get
caffeinated and also around the ship
notice he's got some belongings from the
beach house he's got that mighty hunk
air horn and also the how to hulk binder
that he used to train his cousin jen so
wherever he is going bruce looks like he
plans on being gone for a while and he's
clearly going voluntarily and the fact
that he is bringing his research with
him suggests that he is on a mission
that requires his knowledge something
academic in nature as a consultant not
as a warrior now i've heard from a bunch
of you new rockstars viewers that you've
already signed up for baksu but for
those of you unfortunate uninitiated
boxu is amazing it's a monthly
subscription service that delivers
premium japanese snacks and tea pairings
straight from japan to your door they
source rare snacks from all over the
country and partner with family
businesses to make their own signature
treats all of this curated and delivered
under a new theme every month this is a
box i got this month and this month's
theme is midori moments so midori means
green in japanese and this box reflects
the green rainy season in japan it's got
a wide variety of wasabi matcha and
fruit flavored snacks let's try this
ujimacho waffle
cookie there's filling
it's like the perfect balance of like
sweet and salty
oh my god it's good to just put one of
these in here because i need a million
of these things and here's a little
trick that veteran subscribers like me
know when you really fall in love with a
boxy snack you can order some direct
from their site at a discount both i and
the new rockstar's office have been
receiving these boxes and we love them
i've seen some pics from the office
during unboxing and it's just wild how
excited everyone gets this one
oh my god plus every time you get your
boxu in the mail you can feel good
knowing that you're supporting family
businesses all the way in japan so if
you want to get your own box suit and
enjoy your own midori moment click the
link in the description and use the code
rockstar to get 15 off your order and we
should also remember that this is a
sakarin courier craft this doesn't mean
that the message came from sakhar or
that bruce is necessarily returning to
sakhar the sikharians might just provide
a fleet of ups style messenger crap that
plenty of other planets and societies
all use one theory i pitched last week
on inside marvel was that hulk might be
being summoned as an expert witness or
jury member for whatever trial aeroshem
brought cersei and the other internals
to perhaps in front of the living
tribunal to ascertain the worthiness of
planet earth's existence i truly hope
that some kind of trial like that is
going down somewhere in the cosmos of
the mcu but i don't really know what
film or streaming title we would see it
in there are two areas of study that
bruce banner is considered the mcu's
foremost expert in one is radiation
obviously it's like
i was made for this shield sought him
out in the first avengers film as the
expert to track down the radiation
signatures released by the tesseract
another is what tony stark and asian
voltron called bio organics you know
buyer organics better than anyone by
that i assume tony meant bruce is an
expert in how human tissue responds to
radiation like in the case of the vision
synthesiod the radiation of an infinity
stone now there are plenty of reasons
throughout the cause most people might
want bruce's expertise in these fields
in guardians of the galaxy volume 3 and
mcu film less than a year away by the
way we are going to meet the high
evolutionary the scientists who
experiments with animal tissue to
synthesize beings like probably rocket
and may have helped aisha birth adam
warlock the way will poulter has
described adam warlock is as a super
powerful newborn infant someone
literally born yesterday which me sounds
like vision in age of ultron but without
a soul because ginger kids have no souls
so bruce could have been summoned by the
guardians maybe by the high evolutionary
or by a group of scientists who build
out a morlock in the comics the enclave
to consult on how to give adam warlock a
soul the way bruce and tony imbued
vision with a soul but ultimately i
think marvel studios may have already
indicated their next immediate move for
bruce banner by including him in the
post-credits scene for shang chi
consulting on the beacon in the 10 rings
alongside wang and carol danvers a
beacon that i now believe is summoning
the alien race of the cree ms marvel
with its tin rings easter egg indicated
that there is some connection between
the ten rings and the bengals the
bengals that i think we can assume are
the mcu version of the nega bands
connected to the negative zone and cree
technology since secret evasion and the
marvels are coming next year i think the
likeliest option for hulk's trip here is
to join carol danvers monica rambo nick
fury and any of their squirrel allies in
space name space space hulk as someone
someone resistant to radiation might be
summoned to help free someone kamala
khan from the negative zone using the
second bengal that exists somewhere off
world and perhaps the sokarian ship was
sent because off-world the cosmos is
currently in the midst of a
cree-squirrel war and a sakaran ship
might be seen as a neutral courier craft
that wouldn't be shot down by either
side so i posed a question to you dear
viewers sakar the negative zone the high
evolutionary the living tribunal where
do you think hulk is headed follow me on
tik tok instagram and twitter hey boss
and subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you